dink dink dink dink welcome back to
Julia podcast you're welcome thank you
for thank you welcome back to the
podcast
we are live no not this is live yeah
yeah if you type a comment I'm gonna
read it live text Texas poon Tapper
thanks for joining the stream Wow Wow
this episode is brought to you by me
undies guys get yourself some beautiful
silky soft underwear with me undies it's
officially spring which means it's
spring cleaning time so clean out that
underwear drawer and get some Mandy's go
to me undies Emmy und IES com / - no
Julian get 15% off your first pair of
free shipping and you will be satisfied
with your purchase
guaranteed also guys post mates an
incredible way to get anything you need
from burritos to wine do it with post
mates to Taco Bell to Del Taco french
fries which is kind of weird that they
sell fries is a taco joint but you know
what if you want fries from Del Taco
postmates sink and a judge they're gonna
bring it to you and with a smile on
their face so go to posts go to post
mates in the App Store download the app
and use code Jenna Julian that's just
our name Jenna Julian and you get a
hundred and ten dollars a free delivery
credit for your first seven days start
using free delivery credits right now by
going to the post mates app and using it
to deliver food to your mouth Thank You
sponsors what is that smile that's nice
oh it's not right I hate it I hate I
don't know what you mean it's not right
okay fine it's wrong it's wrong what is
that that's the top from the Chile rise
is still up here I don't know we had a
lot of stuff up here and I didn't
remember to come up here and bring it
down you have to put things back where
they go I'm really sorry I'm really
sorry what kind of weird role reversal
[ __ ] is this you're usually saying that
to me well the difference
is that I will actually take that
downstairs and put it where it belongs
but you didn't one time I will not you
look so cute today put it you look
really cute
anywhere that I feel like that will then
migrate over the course of months to
other places it doesn't belong until one
day you say and then I have to go
rummage through the entire house to find
it
speaking of migrate can i migrate on
over there cuz you look real real fine
today
Julian you really sleep
you look cute no the weather's great and
you know I like how you dress when it's
hot I've I've had time to keep up on my
my glow lotion you know it gives lotion
yeah this is not for those of you that
think that I set out on the Sun all day
I do not because I do have sensitive
skin that I exposed to Sun for many
years that I am terrified of the
consequence artificial Sun yeah it's uh
it's Sun in a bottle inside the bottle
there a brand of self-tanner called Sun
in a bottle I feel like there should be
but if there isn't don't worry we'll
just steal it no look it's sick but yes
you look really pretty yeah I don't know
I used to work at a tanning salon like I
used to ten but even then I put fake tan
over my ten because I was just like yeah
we out of my mind it yeah I mean when
you're drinking the ten tanning lotion
sauce it's you know it hits it was a
requirement for a source Ibiza
well yeah you're not gonna walk into a
tanning salon and see some pale person
working the front desk me like yeah I'm
not gonna go here why the [ __ ] are they
pale yeah I don't know I feel like my
entire 20s was just a weird time I kind
of feel like that may be less weird but
yeah don't do son kids do son if you're
gonna do some do it with sunscreen TM
mm-hmm I put on sunscreen every single
day especially if you have tattoos cover
those things with sunscreen if you want
to keep their you know their color
vibrance
but we had like two weeks of rain and
then all of a sudden this heatwave came
by and was like look ya'll the dogs are
really happy it's honestly it feels like
summer and you know we have really hot
summer's here to the point where when
it's like August we're like okay enough
already we have a small window right now
of outside time yeah and so right now
it's like the pre summer heat and I like
it I will say I like it it feels it
feels good to just go outside and get
this you know the Sun completely beaten
down on you and well yeah cuz once this
summer hits it's like you know the hours
between 10:00 and even like four is the
dogs can go outside for like 5:15 no
like 15 they'll walk around the yard
they'll like lay on the stone and then
they head inside cuz it's just too hot
so yeah well let me bring them in the
pool which we're going to we're gonna
bring all of them then lifejackets out
are you going in the pool buddy you
coming in the pool she's not listening
to you she is she just moved her ear
that's literally that means she's
listening what do we got today so we
have a game that we picked up
it's called you are a liar I'll be
playing today I'm on behalf of Team
Liquid I'm also gonna be playing on
behalf of Team Liquid this is a scrim
okay I'm liquid Jenna Dewan we're not
not on Team Liquid I got signs oh you
signed the contract yeah but the what's
happening with the contract to get lost
in the mail no it's not lost there uh
both of our lawyers are just going over
some of the the language okay so they
didn't get signed then the diction and
once we get done with that could last
for years
it's gonna get signed okay well you know
you're from better or worse I haven't
any sports athlete Congrats but I love
your manager but I get jerseys too
wait I didn't sign up for a manager oh
it's okay we all figured that out oh no
you didn't have a say in it if I don't
get don't worry you still get 10% why do
I feel like this is how the music
industry oh here you get ten I'm your
manager I get 90 wait so I I play the
eSports you know that house that you
just bought give me the keys Oh No yeah
we're gonna try to figure out if we're
liars today cuz basically this game on a
personal level can figure out if you are
a person who lies no Julian that's not
that's not a game it's literally just
fat it's like Snapple caps some of these
are true and some of them are false and
it's up to us to figure out which ones
are true or false you are a liar that's
why we got this game cuz it's called you
are a liar
with that on the front so we're actually
this is the inaugural first game well
first it's been unknown if I say
inaugural but this is the inaugural
match of Team liquids you are a liar
team we're both on that team incredible
it's almost like this isn't even eSports
at all it is eSports
because it's on the e-mini screen the EE
I feel really bad because I should give
credit to who tweeted it but I saw a
tweet this morning like right when I
woke up that said eagerly the presence
of physical real girls somewhere is that
not funny because I think it is like the
term a girl's implies the presence of a
physical girl yeah stupid stupid I'm not
gonna be able to find it I feel bad if
anyone has credit for that that'd be
great
oh by the way last week we did not
podcast that's what it feels like it's
been a million years what we we were
observing
I like how when you take a day off to
like celebrate a holiday you say we're
observing it like you're just looking at
the day we were observing National Aries
Day which was my birthday I had a as
great of a birthday as anyone in
quarantine could ask for
who's the person who said it underscore
SCR seven underscore eager implies the
existence of offline physical girls yeah
we played some video games drank some
alcohol and ate some pad thai right we
ate pad thai for number day yeah it was
good and but anyway yeah so we're gonna
determine if we're a liar so basically
we want you guys to be able to play
along with us so so say Jen is gonna go
right she's gonna pick a card I'm not
gonna look and you're gonna you're not
gonna know either she's not gonna
whisper it to you or show the camera so
that when she reads the fact you will
also be in the dark as to whether or not
is true and you can guess you can guess
so you close your eyes first all right
liquid Jenna don't look looking why
would I cheat why don't you you're
looking right now Julian look away okay
no all the way okay you ready yeah
hippie punch me in the face actually
Julian stop the top two cards I read
already so if he puts it if he picks off
the top get it out of here of course I
picked it off okay I get it
turn around stop no cheating
stop don't look okay none of you guys
look either all right you ready yep
don't look okay okay look directly to
the light in China drinking panda poop
diluted in boiling water is believed to
extend a healthy human's life by at
least 20 years panda poop 20 years
extend a life by 20 years is such a
dress false that's so fun
you are alive oh my god don't point at
me that's rude but yeah I am a liar I
keep that yeah lie panda poop is prized
and China not as a drink but as a
fertilizer for tea plants tea from these
plants can sell for as much as thirty
five thousand dollars per pound
imagine [ __ ] thirty five thousand
dollars pandas be like yeah okay but the
look don't look
I'm actually not gonna look what is that
implying is that implying I did look I
didn't look I did baby I did not look
alright alright okay you I didn't pick
one you rush me stop looking cheater
okay hold on we are good to go
yeah you can look looking how do you
pronounce the word tea SAR SAR sorry
okay Peter the Great the infamous Tsar
of Russia imposed a beard tax in 1698 so
a Russian guy in power imposed a beard
tax it doesn't seem completely
ridiculous but I don't think that's true
I would say that you are a liar I'm not
a lawyer
really Russians who refuse to pay the
beard tax were publicly shaved by police
oh my god oh my god
it gives you this little icon after
publicly shaved by police not just
publicly shamed but publishing shaved
shaved yeah I like on their police but
they have their gun well they have their
weapon they have their flashlight what
your they have a lighter what your they
have a razor it's just a blade it's just
a knife yeah they have their body camp
what you okay yeah you're you're wrong
I'm right why you don't get a liar card
better you might get publicly shamed I
don't know
turn around public shaving phantom
called it public shaving turn around
alright I'm ready
that was quick good job good quickness
yeah you literally just have to pick a
card okay Elvis Presley's grave is no
Elvis I know about him Elvis Presley's
grave is no longer found at his
Graceland home in Memphis Tennessee his
final resting place was moved for
security reasons in 1988 to an
undisclosed location that's definitely
true why would that be false
of course that's that's like the most
realistic sounding scenario I've ever
heard I lied to you the King scrape
continues to be in the backyard of his
former Memphis home you are a liar I am
a liar but you don't get to use that
[ __ ] that's a well-crafted lie right
there and the light turn around team
liquid-liquid Jenna it get lied to okay
don't look most people believe that
mosquitoes are the deadliest animals on
earth but they actually ranked second
humans kill more people than mosquitoes
you are a liar malaria kills more people
than people have you called it
mosquitoes are indeed the deadliest
animals around thank you think about
that for a second no I've thought about
it that's why I called you a liar a
mosquito is the deadliest animal around
and malaria that's crazy dude a girl is
way bigger true no comment no contest
that gorilla wins ten unattended you put
a gorilla in a cage with a mosquito
first of all I would watch it on
pay-per-view second of all the gorilla
wins slam that you'd imagine like the
the whatever they play before a fight to
like hype you oh yeah and
just like a gorilla doing like you're
dragging like a tire and like banging on
stuff like a mosquito like fly right
into the light let's go to Lane kill can
we get a replacement okay
different mosquito I think I see we're
one-on-one okay okay
Kate Middleton do you know who it is
that's a British one right the the Royal
British okay no that's good the royalty
the royalty the royal family Kate that's
that's who that is yeah okay Kate
Middleton briefly worked as a flight
attendant for British Airways to for
meeting and eventually marrying Prince
William Faust Qantas okay who's Qantas
she's Australian she's lying about her
identity
the game is she catfished Prince William
lie are you gonna use the card you are a
liar I am a liar Qantas Kate Middleton
may not have been a flight attendant for
British Airways but her mother was
that's a lot Qantas don't look look away
my turn just ended injuries caused by
the use of smartphones for recreational
purposes like taking photos playing
games and chatting make it the most
dangerous leisure activity in America
what you're a liar
the most dangerous leisure activity in
America is taking you're a liar playing
games in chat again you're a liar that's
statistic whatever that is I'm a liar
I'm a liar by bicycling related injuries
cause more trips to the ER than any
other recreational pastime really
bicycle bicycling bicycling bicycling
say that 10 times bicycling bicycling
bicycling bicycling bicycling basically
basically basically basically basically
basically a bicycle
a nice job it sounds like you're saying
you know like imagine if bicycle was a
planet and the people who lived on it
were bicycling that's what you're saying
okay did you get a liar card Congrats no
I don't have the energy the monster in
the famous horror novel Frankenstein was
a vegetarian [ __ ] dude I don't remember
any scenes with him eating cheese so I'm
gonna call that a lie you are a liar I'm
telling the truth
Mary Shelley the author of Frankenstein
is also believed to have been vegetarian
Mary Shelley yeah yeah saving them and
the moles or as I like to call them
moles go vegan for the moles Julianne
Mary Shelley went vegan for the moles
Julianne all right I don't get a liar
card find turn around I just feel like
it's an interesting thing to put in your
book Frankenstein that he's a vegetarian
well was it even the book explicitly
earned is in the lore of like the world
I you know you don't mean like is it
even just gonna turn okay bye dude I
want a different card don't look okay
the third largest heist in Las Vegas
history occurred when 14 professional
card counters all of whom were
blacklisted from casinos pretended to be
nuns and bilked I've never heard that
word the MGM Grand for 4.4 million in
one day the plot was discovered the next
day but less than half the money was
recovered so I've watched a lot of shows
about like stuff like that and I don't I
feel like that would make a great TV
show that we would have heard about and
I think it's possible that 14 people did
that but I don't think that they were
nuns
and if there was a case where there were
nuns it was on a smaller scale than 14
people okay so I'm gonna call you a liar
I'm a liar
it's just his lie there's no explanation
also bilk to obtain or withhold money
from someone by deceit or without
justification cheat or defraud I like
that word bilked bilked bilked okay
american mountain climber you are a liar
sorry sorry
no one in America climbs mountains
American mountain climber Jordan was
only 13 when he reached the summit of
Mount Everest 13 13 13 13 he didn't even
know how to walk yet
you are a liar there's no way a 13 year
old ma loveth Poorna a 13 year old
mountain climber from India also reached
the summit of Mount Everest but she was
one month older than Jordan Romero she
is the youngest woman to reach the
summit what did you do when you were 13
literally went to the cafeteria and got
pizza nuggets and sat there and like
cried into them I had my friend pitch me
a basketball I know like a baseball I
swung at it with a bat and the bat
bounced off the basketball and knocked
me unconscious that is what I did when I
was 13 that guy climbed Everest when he
was 13 we all develop at different
speeds okay turn around the journey of
life and we never stop never gon stop
turn around a kangaroo cannot jump
backwards you are a liar I've seen
kangaroo fights oh [ __ ] it is true
according to this very credible
card game weight that came from but like
define jump because when they're
standing on their hind legs and they get
into little boxing matches they're like
kind of jumping back I think it means
okay so I travel back yeah I think the
word jump is is like indicates movement
so it's like when you see them jumping
forward and running that sort of that
speed of jump okay can't be done
backwards I think that's my guess yeah
it doesn't matter because you lost so go
okay the graphic designer who created
the iconic Nike swoosh was paid $35 like
in total just what it says did you hear
that
I didn't let it out it was like an
internal burp 35 bucks honestly it's
kind of a sick deal I would yeah I think
that's accurate
yeah true it is true so that guy got
startled when Carolyn Davidson showed
her swoosh designed to Phil Knight the
head of Nike he didn't like it but he
used it anyways
she was further compensated the years
later okay okay I would love to know how
much he was further compensated for
because oh my god
hopefully her fair worth because that
it's like well filming all right don't
look okay hold on I'm not ready I'm
looking at you're looking at your phone
I'm sorry I was I was texting my friends
I'm in a group chat turn around okay
ready
hold on I'm not ready okay go
me and these are three times salty and
cotton true yes it is true you can get
15% off your first pair and free
shipping with code Jim julienned true or
false true they come out with new prints
all the time and they have onesies as
well true or false true
dang dude shouts out to this game for
knowing what sponsors we had dude shouts
out me undies more undies equals less
laundry I love that math get yourself
some babies and never do laundry again
more undies means in theory more laundry
well depends on how you look at things
and also who you live with and how how
long that you can store dirty underwear
somewhere okay just you know what you
know we love me undies we have tons of
me on these Jenna wears her onesies all
the time they're great loungewear
they're great gamer where they're great
Netflix watching where they're even
great
I don't know work out where you've
worked out in those onesies before you
can do it depends what you're doing but
yeah heavy sweating no well you can go
to me and these comm slash Angelina and
get yourself a pair and see how you like
it or you can sign up with their
membership you get savings site-wide you
get free shipping and you get new
ridiculously soft undies delivered to
your door once a month it's pretty great
so go to me undies comm / - no Julian
okay you get 15% off your first pair
free shipping in 100% satisfaction
guarantee meaning if you not 100%
satisfied for whatever reason you're
like I want my money back they will give
you your money back
doubt it will happen cuz me and these
are great and you're gonna love them but
go to meet undies comm / Jenna Julian to
get their ridiculously ridiculously soft
and wonderful underwear check it out
also guys post mates if you want some
pad thai do it with post mates I'm sure
there's a lot of places in your area
that will make a delicious delicious
bowl of Pad Thai and you can not dirty
one single dish in your house if you log
on to post mates right now when you use
code Jenna Julian and you order whatever
you feel like if it's not Pad Thai you
can maybe get some pad thai you can get
a hundred and ten dollars of free
delivery credit for your first seven
days of you
when you enter code Jen and Julian after
downloading the postmates SAP so check
it out if you never use postmates it's
24 hours a day 365 days a year there are
delivery people who work for post mates
who will go fetch food from a restaurant
nearby that you've ordered from online
using their very intuitive menu and
ordering system within the app it's all
on your phone and they deliver it so
quick and you can watch their progress
of where they are so you can time them
there's a very clear ETA you can
communicate with them there's
substitutes available whatever you want
post mates is there to bring it to you
it's pretty great so download the post-
app use coach engine and start saving
right now with $110 a free delivery
credit check it out Thank You postman
it's great up Thank You sponge look away
ok now you're actually gonna go yep ok
I'm ready
the Cougar mountain lion and Puma are
three of the largest species of wild cat
found in North America mmm North America
the Cougar the mountain lion and the
Puma are three of the largest species of
cat wild cat found in North America also
I know I think it's just a matter of if
all of them are found in North America
because from my understanding they're
kind of all very similar and but like
the I don't think there's Cougars in
North America but there's what's the
other Puma and not like mountain lion
there's definitely Pumas and there's
definitely mountain lions I don't think
that there's Cougars Beverly Hills you
are a liar okay sorry you say check
Beverly Hills I'm a liar because these
are three are they actually in all the
same species okay yeah no you're not
dumb as hell you even said it they're
very similar
well yeah cuz I know I've lived in
places more where people call it a Puma
or they call it a mountain lion but I
also didn't know if they were
genetically the same but it's like the
same species yeah so
yes but they're also like in terms of
wild cat that's like all we got
yes not like this of a big cats no
that's it that's it and I'm an expert
okay well I'm dumb close your eyes
turn around I'm not looking stop
okay okay here we go here we go Charles
Dickens had ten children all of whom
also became authors of course none of
them became as well-known as their
legendary father can you repeat the
question Charles Dickens had ten
children damn he'd be [ __ ] Charles
Dickens had ten children say it again
Charles Dickens had ten children Charles
Dickens had tential true he'd be putting
that ticket okay true it's a lie
although he did have ten children none
were authors what you just said Charles
Dickens had children that was the urn no
you stopped it after ten children got
cheated
I literally read the whole card you got
distracted you read it like three times
in complete non entirety cuz it was
funny
no misleading misleading I get to go
again okay you can go again
you said Charles Dickens had ten
children like that part of the sentence
alone three times I said yes and you
said yes he did have ten children but it
was a lot they weren't all offense I
didn't know about the author's part by
heck did I read the question you said he
sticks his dick in that was very
distracting I'm in school right now okay
you're looking at the inside of your
palm yeah the inside of my palms
disgusting okay
there are 887 stone boy statues on
Easter Island and all of them are male
how do I say that word I think it's
pronounced um wha no that's not right
boys my statue
other hotmail yeah true yeah you're
right yeah
they well they talked about them on
ancient aliens a lot to that they're
actually like alive kind of like that
they're the spirit or like a person in
there and that they're alive because I
know that there was one in like the UK
somewhere and they really really really
wanted it back
because it's not like a statue to them
that's like a more meaningful you're
it's like a being they just want it to
come home that's pretty cool I'm I'm
pretty sure they got it back I don't
remember
I hope they did turn I hope they do you
to turn around go the hardest substance
in the human body is the mandible or job
on mmm no it's your uh femur or whatever
this big one in your thigh is no it's a
lie you just said it's a lie right but
it's not for what you said is it your
teeth its tooth enamel damn no that
means so [ __ ] dominant means a hammer
can go right into your mouth and nothing
would happen no no it's the enamel not
like the whole tooth is that what
toothpastes have an amal in it or no
enamel like strengthening damn chemicals
when yo ii guess should have been your
father you don't got a right why you
were not to have a student and that is a
lie see you get a like hard
go ahead oh wait I just get actually
give to you oh thank you okay the voice
of actor Mel Blanc famous for as the
voice of Bugs Bunny and Woody Woodpecker
also voiced Gideon the cat in the 1940
animated film Pinocchio this is a very
nice question I guess true you're right
it is true during the making of this
classic film the Gideon character was
changed and became mute except for Mel's
single hiccup sound for Gideon which is
repeated three times those other voice
recordings for the cat character were
erased
that's cute so the thing about this game
that I don't like is if you catch a true
like a truth or a fact and you're like
that's true you don't get anything yeah
also it says you are a liar not not you
are not a liar why that's [ __ ] well
maybe you do get a card and we've just
been doing it wrong well I didn't read
the instructions yeah me either
so you turn around okay okay go the Roma
people also known as gypsies originally
came from northern India Roma people
I thought gypsies were like wait first
of all I'm sorry if that's problematic
if that's a word that is offensive blame
this Jam dude I thought that was more
like Europe like Eastern Europe okay so
I'm gonna say you are a liar it's true
okay [ __ ] me then Roma people make up
various subgroups of tribes living all
over the world but there's no reliable
record of just how many people comprise
the total worldwide Roma population if
this is problematic taking out with out
set media they are a french-canadian
company go to the TV hz6 stop I don't
think that they're trying to be like
derogatory in any way your turn okay
lady turn me lady I'm bored stop looking
okay
George Clooney's Bulldog died of a
rattlesnake bite that's definitely true
yeah that is true that's horrible
oh that's really sad that is we were
hiking one time up on the trail that we
go to with buddy
we're like hyper aware that there's
rattlesnakes up there and it's just
slithered out right in front of us like
bellows and rattle rattle at us because
it was like excuse me I'm crossing and
we were like yo do you think and then it
crossed and then we walked by yeah it
[ __ ] rattled at us that was a lot I
think because those rattlesnakes live
near a trail like I haven't heard of too
many people having
bites and stuff up there like they must
be used to the foot traffic there's a
lot of bikes for sure yeah but like he
could have easily just turned around and
bit bunny Oh or or any of our dogs and
killed any of absolutely like the
scariest part is you you you have to be
vigilant like you you could very easily
not see the rattlesnake and if it's not
in a good mood
it might just [ __ ] bite you and
rattle at you well and not only the dogs
but us but I think what's really scary
about a dog is like you have limited
time to get them treatment no you have a
little bit more time if you're a human
being you know it's really sad and awful
feel bad for George Clooney I don't
mmm-hmm you turn we go lightning never
strikes in the exact same location more
than once during a single storm
absolutely false that's such a bad card
I feel like if you have a metal pole and
it's just standing up there it's just
gonna keep going [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ]
you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you the location has
no bearing on a storm's electrical
activity lightning can certainly strike
the same place one of the ones yeah this
is the dumbest card ever you've never
been in a plane that's being struck by
lightning it's like [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you and it's also
terrifying know sometimes I can't feel
my arms all right I feel that level of
fear
I haven't here that's yours I haven't
been in a plane being struck by
lightning I feel like that's kind of a
unique thing to go through but I haven't
gone through terrifying I hated it hated
it okay people are either left brain or
right brain dominant the left being the
logical side and the right side being
the creative no it's all the way around
left is creative you are a liar I'm a
liar because no one has a dominant
pretty hemisphere while certain
functions sometimes dominate specific
brain regions both sides of the brain
are generally equal in their activity
but you refer to left brain as artistic
no I thought that was yeah but I guess
it doesn't matter I got the card thank
you you're welcome
don't look look away okay glass is a
liquid that moves extremely slow over
time that's
true no it is false glass is an
amorphous solid having a stronger
connectivity needs building blocks and
liquids more so anoying
amorphis solid that is not a solid it's
so [ __ ] annoying no because I grew up
in a house that was a hundred years old
and so like the original happy birthday
to your house
the original panes of glass like are
thicker at the bottom because it moves
over time because it's an amorphous
solid but that's so [ __ ] annoying
like of course it's not a liquid it's
glass you know but like over time that's
over it's really misleading question it
is misleading that's pretty cool he's
got to notice the glass like change
shape as you as you grew up congratz of
it I win though yeah one time he threw a
softball through one of the panes and
sad you know is it's like a regional
glass we had to get part of it replace
because I pitched a whole last softball
through nice dude we had a makeshift
batting cage in our backyard and it did
not work we would hit it through and
break glass all the time like you're
sure don't look Oh God oh great two
things found in many American
restaurants are fourteen ounce glass
bottles of Heinz ketchup and coca-cola
neither of which are part of a healthy
diet in fact there is more sugar in one
14 ounce bottle of ketchup than there is
in one can of coca-cola more sugar and
one bottle of ketchup than there is in a
can
let's think about this so a can of coke
I want to say has anywhere from like 30
to like 38 grams of sugar maybe like 32
to 42 grams a bottle of ketchup I feel
like has way more because it's a can of
soda is one serving a bottle of ketchup
has what 20 servings I'm gonna go with
weight read the questions asking you if
the bottle of ketchup has more sugar I
think it does yeah you're right what
does it say how much no that's true cool
cool you are a liar no
you gotta write though okay don't look
okay the best way to avoid a thing of
thanksgiving post-meal coma is to avoid
the turkey due to high amounts of
serotonin producing chemical tryptophan
found in its meat okay but that's listen
hear me out for one second
turkey does contain tryptophan yeah but
by saying the best way to avoid needing
a nap like that's subjective they phrase
these questions very somehow all right
I'm gonna say that it's true but if it
says false the best way to avoid getting
tired is to like drink water I'm gonna
be pissed
okay so you say it's true yeah it's
false because it says Turkey contains no
more tryptophan than any other meats I
didn't listen to that part of the
question I was too mad I was true really
I thought I thought that was a unique to
turkey meat I'm mad about the first part
of the question
hi I'm okay due to high amounts of the
serotonin producing chemical tryptophan
found in its meat lie Turkey contains no
more tryptophan than any other meat what
okay so that so you're saying like
people eat chicken every day and there's
the same exact amount of tryptophan
content in a chicken breast as there is
in turkey I guess that people make a big
deal about your tired familiar thanks
any where I feel like this is where's
the fat I mean I don't I don't know if I
believe that okay I don't care okay
alright the largest alligator ever found
in New York suit sewer system was 9 feet
long and was nicknamed poo poo by
sanitation workers false it's false you
are a liar the only alligators ever
discovered have been small and are most
likely released pets there is no proof
that alligators can actually live for
any length of time in New York sewers a
9-foot alligator in sewers have nobody
named him poo poo poo poo it's weirdly
the most believable part of that call
him poopy okay no poo poo I turn look
anyway
okay here we go at the end of a
traditional wedding reception in French
Polynesia the bride's family lay
facedown side by side in the dirt and
the bride and groom walk across them
range pollen you Joe
you know I don't I'm not familiar with
the customs of a French Polynesian
wedding and I feel like I'm set up to
fail right now because if I say you're a
liar you're set up to fail this whole
game is a setup to no no no I like this
game is fun he's meant to just know I
know I know
I want to say you're a liar nope it's
true the ug tradition takes place on the
Marquesas island of French Polynesia
they face down in dirt it's probably fun
you don't want to let your I would total
it if I went to my friend's wedding or
like my anyone in my family's wedding
and they were like right lay down I'm
gonna run over you'd be like hell yeah
Congrats y'all know you'd be like okay
you ready yeah turn around
chocolate syrup was often used to
simulate blood in black-and-white movies
huh that's funny it's got the right
consistency I feel like maybe it's a
little thick I'm going through that's
true what a really good idea it's a good
idea why the [ __ ] not right that's funny
okay ready yeah
if stung by a jellyfish oh no I don't
want it urinating on the injury will
help break down the toxins and reduce
pain this is because of the high acidic
pH levels of urine see this is one of
those things that like too many
questions
so I think we can all agree that we've
heard that peeing on a jellyfish sting
no no I've heard pooping on it does
Julian know that is rubbing it on this
Julian uh I don't think it cares it but
I do think that the the portion of the
sentence where it says that it can
decrease the pain it is true but I also
feel like that completely depends on
what kind of jellyfish or thong you will
reduce pain is is a weird phrase cuz
it's like that's very subjective reduce
pain like that's not a medical
assessment of like how to treat
something it will reduce pain ya know
and this is a drug like if some benefit
jellyfish urinating on the injury will
help break down the toxins and reduce
pain this is because of the high acidic
pH levels of urine right but like also
that last sentence I know yeah okay I'm
gonna say that it's true because I think
peeing on a jellyfish sting does do
something but I don't know if it's that
but it definitely doesn't cure it but I
also think that it has to do with the
type of jellyfish that's done you okay
just tell me I'm a liar so basically it
retracts that last sentence the pH of
urine is dependent on what has been
eaten that's so annoying even the acidic
urine isn't enough to effectively
neutralize the alkaline venom of a
jellyfish vinegar and baking soda is
more helpful but you just more helpful
who cares if it's more helpful we're
talking about paste my guy yeah go into
a doctor's office is probably more
helpful to not getting stung by a
jellyfish yeah how do you reduce pain of
getting stung by jellyfish don't get
stung by a jellyfish yeah Gigi's your
turn liquid Julian ready yeah
Canadian bacon isn't actually called
Canadian bacon in Canada I know that's
true they call it him yeah what the
Americans loves Canadian bacon is called
back bacon or peameal bacon in Canada
she meal yep you mean people bacon bacon
you want some pew pew pew here we go oh
you just got them all excited Oh
Jonathan godfather of John Lennon and
Yoko Ono's Sean Sean Lennon Godfather
I don't know [ __ ] it why not that's true
true Elton John is the Godfather to
several celebrity children including two
of David and Victoria Beckham's children
okay don't care okay yep unless you the
tongue is mapped into four areas with
different taste buds per region that
region proteins for detecting sweet
though that release proteins for
detecting sweet sour salty in bitter so
let me just get this straight
four areas meaning if I taste sugar on
the bitter detecting part of my tongue
it will not detect it right of sugar
that's [ __ ] false right you are a liar
all right gluey bats use their
echolocation to determine safe flight
patterns due to their near blindness
that's true no it's not surprisingly
some bats have better night vision than
humans bats use echolocation to detect
tiny objects like mosquitoes in total
darkness this game is just like such a
debate it's like your your name is
jeanna true or false true no it's not no
it's not I talked to your mom just amore
all right and you're stupid all right
Carm are you done you want a hug are we
done with the game who's got more liar
cards they have like an internal timer
and they know exactly when the podcast
should be done yeah no oh are you
standing on my hair I can't no no no all
right bud you're a liar Kermit you are a
liar even like that
well I had fun playing this game it's
but it's definitely fun yeah like I love
like that's why I like wits & wagers
because some of the things that you're
guessing are like so [ __ ] random that
you're like how am I supposed to know
this but that's what makes it fun yeah
like when we played against your mom and
your brother like even like really smart
brainiacs can't do that well sometimes
because it's like yeah you just have to
take the best guess this would be
actually this would be a fun game to
play with some sort of betting element
totally like we can introduce like chips
or something and then when it's like a
little tricky trick question you just
get [ __ ] furious yep flip the table
it doesn't matter yeah I just flip the
table flip the table well thanks for
listening to another episode of GG's
good games will be we're gonna go back
to it we're gonna hit the old gamer
locker room now and hit the showers
after this long intense scrim of you are
a liar because R in the life of an
eSports athlete anyway I hope you guys
are you know staying safe and having a
good routine and keeping your spirits up
as best you can
we appreciate you listening to the
podcast if you're listening I also don't
know like I know a lot of people listen
to podcasts on commutes and I know a lot
of commutes are on freeze right now and
I've even listened to some podcasts that
I've said like are people listening
because everyone's at home and uh we
don't care and if you are great and
we're happy to be here for you if you're
not no worries and if you come back and
you missed a bunch of episodes that's
all good too
we just hope you guys are doing well and
we appreciate your spending any amount
of time with us so thank you guys have a
great week and we'll see you next time
on gentle puck
[Music]